euh bon invités suivants est encore plus
rare à la télévision ces derniers temps
que pierre arditi
mais il a choisi tout le monde en parle
pour venir parler de son livre de son
premier livre voici jacques dutronc
ici
jacques dutronc mesdames messieurs
comment ça va ça va la dernière fois
qu'on s'est vus c'était il ya dix ans
vous vouliez sortir van gogh n'était pas
aux folies bergère qui s'ils sont
solides derrière
j'étais déjà là toi avec ces infos intox
absolument calme et moi j'ai que ça
alors c'était extraordinaire parce
qu'elle a sortis de cette émission de
double jeu on s'était dit mme alors
dutronc il nous fait que des aphorismes
sur toutes ces réponses sont des
aphorismes et alors effectivement quand
gilles bouquin y en a pas mal qui était
dans l'émission qui sont mardi puis
c'était une reprise de vos interviews
j'en ai retrouvé généreux souhaite pas
mal dans pensées répliques que je montre
nos amis voilà pensées répliques
on cherche midi éditeur joue mon garçon
vous le faites pas à quoi ça c'est bon
signe
jacques dutronc est excusé
vous êtes choqués audrey dutronc ça les
boys n'ont comme exergue du livre de
jacques dutronc ya une phrase qui résume
le livre je n'ai strictement rien à dire
mais je tiens à ce que ça se sache
tu es à net et précis alors on a envie
évidemment quand on est ici comme moi ce
soir de lire tout le livre alors
évidemment ce pas est possible vous
comprenez bien fallu retourner
enfin alors je vais en citer
quelques-unes au fur et à mesure mais
bon alors il a une que j'ai noté qui me
fait rigoler c'est je suis toujours à
l'heure à mes rendez vous comme ça je
peux partir plus un cd légal est là
quand on vous demande vous buvez pour
noyer votre rendez vous répondez non
pour lyrique et seulement est alors
votre grande phrase ou plus grandes
phrases la vie est une maladie mortelle
transmissibles sexuellement bien aussi
hier le cil cancer gehrig du cigare j'ai
arrêté de croire au père noël le jour où
dans une galerie marchande il m'a
demandé un autographe voilà quoi passer
que des trucs comme ça
les cats et je suis très fidèle quand je
fais l'ouverture j'ai fait aussi la
fermeture que j'aime bien là on va
parler de votre vie jacques 1
je vais être un peu long parce que je
suis pas tout jeune non plus mes bagages
et on y va
vous vous souvenez de la barrière
jean souvenu de la barrière bien sûr
bien alors vous êtes né dans un car de
police en 1943 pratique - c'était le
couvre-feu en 43 et de bombardements
alliés vous êtes né dans un car de
police voilà ce qui fait que j'ai été
déclaré la mairie du 17e voilà et après
avec votre ami gainsbourg quand vous
étiez ramassé par des cars de police
en fin de nuit bien après et finalement
ça vous changez pas beaucoup puisque
vous étiez né dans un car de plus
j'avais une impression et oui c'est
exact de redevenir fabre s'était c'était
ça avait le but
serge ne le savaient pas lui mais enfin
le but c'était ça je revenais dans
l'enfance
ici on fait alors votre père était
ingénieur des ponts et chaussées mais le
dos un seigneur des mines
oui c'est ça c'est qu'en fait c'était un
faux parce qu'ils étaient musiciens
amateurs et c'est vrai il ya déjà le
sens de la fantaisie propre dutronc
amateurs et de il aimait beaucoup la
musique il joue incognito avec un faux
nez et souvent pour la plupart des on
appelait ça des dactylos aller dans les
mêmes balles vers la bastille dont pour
pas reconnaître leur tour liée entre
guillemets c'est mon père m'a téléphoné
où il se déguisait avec l'upa quoi il
s'agit mais il jouait il jouait très mal
et les personnes seules est aperçu joué
pendant 50 ans il avait un truc comme
mousse qui fumait beaucoup il ya une
phrase dans le vif survie vous dites ça
doit faire 70 ans qu'ils fument
quand il reste bénigne et la planche
pour pouvoir fumer et manière là tels
renoir car c'est génial quand même mais
c'est vrai il avait il avait une
habitude aussi votre père qui était
qu'il va aussi vous avez hérité beaucoup
de votre père il balance elle était
énorme attaque il était à côté d'une
jolie femme balançait ap énorme et il
disait ne vous inquiétez pas je dirais
que c'est moi
d'ailleurs un nom en france du jeune
dutronc ou bon l'école ça vous motive et
pas spécialement non
vous aviez des rhumatismes c'est vrai
c'est vrai j'avais et votre mère me
faisait des mots d'excusés c'est sympa
pour sa sage et la plus belle collection
du lycée condorcet redmond excuses elle
disait c'était comme je voulais rien le
jour mon fils a rechuté été dans le coup
votre mère mais c'était ça plutôt relais
chute dans l'escalier elle va voir dans
l'ascenseur sinon nous quitter l'école à
ces jeunes et vous entrez dans une école
de dessin industriel mais votre vocation
c'était vétérinaire comme tous les
mondes ouverts à part cyclistes avaient
soigné sa difficile à lui le faire donc
vous avez 200 souris non mais à peu près
la vie privée ça que j'ai changé puisque
j'ai quarante quatre chats maintenant et
quand vous partir en vacances
il était dans le train et vous mettiez
de l'autre cologne sur les souris mais
ça c'est lorsque je joue en ce moment
j'en achetais no tou s'est pas créée
donc il ya des combats énorme entre
familles de souris dans lequel se
sentent tout gp refus mais l'autre
colonne d'eau qui se reconnaissaient
l'autre colonne tout ça s'arrange et
tranquillement sans bagarre alors à
l'époque bas vous redis j'ai beaucoup
parce que j'ai pas grand chose les
boulevards les italiens au cinoche vous
écoutiez les camelots sur les grands
boulevards arriver ça vous plaisez y
avait le père la souris sous les côtes
du bénin avec génie qu'est ce qu'ils
vendaient pas une souris une fois de
plus c'est non mais qu était tenu par
l'espèce de deux petits fils faisait
peur
hormis l'arrivée de les cogner vous ah
bah oui messieurs c'est marrant parce
que je découvre que d'abord dutroux
était au lycée condorcet qui paraît très
loin du lycée jacques decour ont le même
âge donc on mettrait même quartier que
je faisais aussi les grands boulevards
johnny très bien et à la souris avec les
mots l'exclu de la mer de dutronc
ressemble beaucoup au monde excuses de
la mienne et vous alors vous avez en
commun aussi des mets beaucoup les chats
ces derniers et d'avoir d'essayer de
fumer le cigare
mais ce soir c'est bien donc
en fait notre vraie passion jacques
dutronc c'était la musique est alors à
la trinité au soir de la trinité en là
c'est extraordinaire ça aussi c'est un
peu comme votre histoire m'a dit des
choses comme ça imaginez dans ce square
de la tribu c'est le sport de la trinité
il y avait jacques dutronc qui traînait
y'avait johnny hallyday qui à l'époque
s'appelait jean philippe smet
il y avait dit mitchell nom claude moine
bac
donc vous imaginez que dans ce petit
square vous allez les mecs qui jouent et
qui était ado c'est des gens qui sont
devenus parmi les chanteurs les plus les
plus connus dans l'est dans les dix ans
suivant quoi élevé ces jours ci elle et
serge aussi aller à l'école communale
rue blanche aussi c'est marrant ça quand
même vous avez tous étaient là c'était
un hit talent c'est rigolo ça alors vous
faites un premier groupe qui s'appelle
des tritons peut-être je suis moi je le
sais demandez moi et puis après si vous
connaissiez le taureau les cyclones
quand même et savez vous étiez pas le
taureau vous annonce devait être le
guitariste de faire partie d'un des
cyclones mais j'ai joué avec mitchell
surtout longtemps
ouais mais au départ je jouais que
johnny est un espèce de groupe pas mal
ils commandent génial époque vous seriez
est-ce qu'on sentait qu'il avait
vraiment ce potentiel et ça se sentait
bien sûr un jour jacques dutronc un peu
le dire je crois parce que maintenant il
ya prescription du fiancé les odeurs
thierry science et à la dernière minute
tout était prêt c'est vrai il va voir la
famille
il leur dit bah non je vais pas à
l'écouté votre fille et les gens y
croient que c'est une plaisanterie
j'espère que ils ont enfin compris
j'espère bamako elle attend encore
qu'elle nous attend non mais j'ai un peu
honte avec le fameux ouais j'ai un peu
honte maintenant mais enfin si je les
fais à ce moment là c'est qu'il fallait
que je le faisais les mieux oui bah oui
sinon je serai pas la seule manon alors
ils ont dit les beaux parents quand il
leur a dit ça il est drôle pour marie
hitwise qui savait c'est quand même à
l'époque on disait vous savez je fais de
la musique etc où ça où je chante je ne
sais quoi c'est où je fais j'essaye de
jouer la comédie
je sais pas quoi mais qu'est ce qui vous
fait à part ça c'était les défraiements
cette époque là ensuite jacques dutronc
part en allemagne comme johnny hallyday
comme elvis presley il était de bon ton
à l'époque de faire son service
militaire en allemagne
quand on voulait devenir une rock star
et on retourne donc mitchell les pirates
et champions vous devenez directeur
artistique en insistant du actes
racistes j'évoque il avoue commencer à
écrire des chansons et en 65 vous
rencontrer jacques lanzmann quelle
époque avec temps chef de lui
collaboration extrêmement fructueuse
évidemment puisque vous avez fait parmi
les plus grandes chansons françaises les
plus classiques en tous les cas
et puis comme vous trouvé personne pour
les chanter vous décidez de les chanter
vous quoi oui c'est pas venu tout de
suite ça non
j'ai chanté ça tout à fait en touriste
puis je me suis retrouvé là la can
devant des caméras
je me suis retrouvé la télévision j'ai
dit bon ben alors autant continuer oui
ça vous a pris pas comme ça quoi mais en
sursaut c'est pour ça que je n'ai jamais
eu l'air d'y croire en fait parce que
c'est parce que vous êtes noir vous êtes
victime un peu du syndrome ce que
j'appellerais le syndrome julien clerc
c'est à dire c'est à dire que julien
clerc il a fait des mélodies formidable
écrit les mélodies extraordinaire on
parle toujours de ses paroliers
vous remarquerez on parle de maurice
vallet on parle de roda gil on parle de
dabadie maintenant on parle de carla
bruni bon on oublie simplement que je
viens car toutes les chansons qu'il a
chanté c'est en général lui qui la
composaient dutronc c'est pareil on a
beaucoup parlé de lanzmann on a dit les
paroles pour me laver tous là la façon
d'interpréter avec cette distance ce
recul que vous aviez est en fait les
musiques c'est vous qui les avez fait
rêver
il fit un bon compositeur bonbons
sûrement compositeur de chansons mais
c'est vrai il a une phrase sur la
modestie dans son livre qu'est ce qu'il
dit c'est l'art d'être doué deux fois
mais je te dis à quelqu'un vous êtes
sûrement mais non mais messi
c
ça c'est un truc regarderai je suis en
train d'essayer de me nommer ouvrait
dans la cus
j
là
au hockey
w
m
ceux ci
je sais pas
les accords
parler
valet
on va
c'est le plus grand
le plus élégant
avec ses longs ou bien sanglant la scène
quand il savait
quand il se traite un petit jard santé
pour le vin nouveau leader
il est sympa et intime en méfier c'est
un trio jacques dutronc
qu'est-ce que connaissent tant au plan
défensif et qu'elle est très vous dites
c'est plus moi aujourd'hui ou qu'est-ce
que c'est bien et c'est bien c'est très
classique si vous êtes content ou ça
vous fait chier entendre ça bah parce
que quand je les vois que ça va abanda
corps d'armée vous êtes tellement voyez
comment vous êtes quoi on a toujours
envie de me faire plaisir de voir
sourire fêlé heureux ça va aller
audrey marnay et catherine barma me
demandent de vous demander si vous aimez
les chansons de jacques dutronc n'a
recommandé le demande mais elles ont en
fait personne ne pense que mon père est
un grand fan ah ouais ouais c'est ma
grand mère et ma grand mère elle adorait
ça donc tu en sors bien ouais bah oui
non c'est vrai qu'à l'époque en plus il
ya un truc extraordinaire est devenu
l'idole des jeunes un moment avec un
personnage très décalé parce qu'ils
avaient tous les cheveux longs
évidemment et vous avez les cheveux
courts un petit costard un peu un peu
étriqué vous aviez pas d'opinion
politique à l'époque tu m'en étais pour
la paix au vietnam vous étiez vous en
foutiez de ça c'était pas par
provocation des autres c'est que grâce à
la chanson les play-boys j'étais habillé
à l'oeil
j'avais des pompes de chez garmin
j'avais des réductions suivant partout
chez fauchon tous les deux ont reçu la
mettrons ça c'était pas mal mais on peut
dire une chose c'est que vous êtes un
peu années 50 c'est à dire votre style
d'humour de façon dead ça fait plus
penser aux années 50 que que non mais
c'est pas un reproche à dans les années
5o rêver non mais c'est pas un reproche
parce que regarder le canular que budget
par exemple les canulars de canulars
c'était des canulars très années 50
c'était un canular qui consistait à
appliquer les pompes à lui acheter les
mêmes en plus petit
or le lendemain le mec où elle apporte
il faut laisser prendre
elle avait quatre tailles demoiselle est
d'essayer de les mettre ils pensaient
que ces pierres et gonfler si à chaque
fois il y avait toujours la main mais
qu'à lui fait un pote du représentant
qu'ils aient c'est le chauffage par le
sol ça fait j'ai gonflé les filles avec
la c4
et puis on avait un autre si c'était de
de mettre un nez trop énormes dans un
papier journal on l'a fait cela mais je
n'ai jamais fais moi de mettre le papier
le journal le maïs sortez de là bas ils
venaient un grand coup de pied
évidemment dans le pays choi youn a
remis réflexe alors un jour j'ai demandé
la plus grande joie de votre carrière
mais vous m'avez dit pas ce que je
possède déjà les mêmes questions que
tout le monde peut s'en apercevoir et 50
je n'ai pas changé et c'est pourrez vous
m'avez répondu c'est le jour où j'ai eu
un gala annulé à 8 heures je suis rentré
dans un hôtel pourri pour lire les pieds
nickelés
c'était la plus grande joie de sa
carrière et la plus grande déception
la plus grande déception on avait
répondu c'était décide de me masturber
avec les pieds nickelés
j'ai très très léger en place et montrer
ce qu'ils sont alors bon après vous avez
eue avec l'usman bouge pas qu'il y eu
des problèmes j'en sais rien à ma façon
vous êtes moins vu v - travailler
ensemble et vous êtes retrouvés il ya
quelques années grâce à moi parce que
j'avais organisé 40 ans de 45 tours
c'était les meilleurs 45 cours des 40
dernières années
évidemment le gagnant ça a été il est
cinq heures paris l'absolument normal
parmi toutes les chansons de l'après
guerre justement est ce jour là bas vous
êtes retrouvé
j'ai pas beaucoup revu par la suite ont
fait au moins 1 mais le plaisir de vous
revoir ensemble